tu as une copie non comme si t'aimais
pas la chatte bah maintenant que le mot
chatte est sorti de votre bouche je me
demande si j'aime toujours ça en fait
berger
une femme qui me comprenne j'ai jamais
vu
en mer avoir une relation avec
et encore le drake de views
tout seul sur un building à Toronto les
gens dans le vide à me demander ce que
ça fait d'être accompagné
[ __ ] mais qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
qu'est-ce que vous foutez aidez-moi je
descends mais vous pouvez rêver pour
avoir vos cinq étoiles se faire uber je
vous signale honnêtement on dirait votre
jumelle ah la vache ouais c'est vrai
qu'elle me ressemble
je suis désolé je vous assure c'était
complètement dingue tu sors avec une
vraie renoire je ne me suis jamais
sentie aussi compris par qui que ce soit
de toute ma vie et ça te plaise ou non
on est ensemble maintenant évidemment
que ma copine je vais lui demander de
lui pousser tu as parlé à sa famille
ouais j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de
les rencontrer c'est tout alors comment
ça va racontez-moi tout je veux tout
savoir le boulot ça va
lui c'est ton grand-père blanc qui
revient me hanter ça va être de ma faute
donc tu veux épouser ma fille ouais
ouais je le veux et bien il sera tu peux
toujours essayer
il me déteste toi non plus tu peux pas
dire que tes parents ont hâte de voir ma
tête de blague sur la photo de famille
j'ai du mal à y croire tu es vraiment
magnifique je trouve que la police a
toujours fait vraiment de la merde avec
la communauté noire j'aime bien tes
tresses merci exhibit avait des tresses
on s'est construit une vie de rêve tous
les deux il faut juste qu'on la préserve
tous musulman ah c'est génial que je
porte en ce moment est un cadeau qui n'a
été offert par l'honorable Louis faraka
êtes-vous familier avec le travail de
notre leader disons que je sais plutôt
bien ce qu'il a dit à propos des Juifs
c'est le moment de passer à table
[Musique]
ma famille
je crois que j'en ai pas la force vous
savez techniquement ce sont les Juifs
les premiers esclaves vous comparez le
low cost à l'esclavage vous pouvez faire
passer les patates par ici notre peuple
est arrivé ici sans rien comme tout le
monde cette conversation commence
vraiment à me mettre mal à l'aise
ou pas
c'est quoi son délire cousin blanc c'est
moi cousin blanc c'est pas moi en tout
cas ok c'est moi
[Musique]